in today's video we're going to be
focusing on a crucial update here on the
P Cycle top indicator talking about the
historical Tendencies we see in 2019
2015 but even more importantly the
harving year and how does that influence
price when it comes to the P Cycle top
moving averages the harving years have
their own Tendencies compared to the
preh harving years so we'll be talking
about that in a lot more detail so
subscribe to the channel for more videos
like this in the future like this video
if you enjoy content like this going
forward and let's Dive Right In so the
Haring year 2020 for instance this is a
very important year for Bitcoin because
we tend to see upside deviation downside
deviation and once that final deviation
occurs we see support holding of the
orange 111 day moving average the same
thing was the case in 2016 so that's
also another Haring year and you can see
here holding of support of the P Cycle
top moving average all the way to new
alltime highs however in the preh
harving year you can see lot of
oscillation around this moving average
so very different Tendencies also
happening in 2019 oscillation around
this moving average so now that we're
transitioning slowly outside of the preh
harving year it's important to note that
we're going to be exiting this
oscillation type of behavior that we've
been seeing all of this year in line
with historical tendencies in the preh
harving year we're going to be
transitioning into the Haring year and
so things are going to probably start
looking more similar to successful
retests of the P Cycle moving average
which is why it's important to
understand that we maybe have one month
left for a potential downside deviation
below the P Cycle moving average maybe
if we do get some sort of retest then a
drop into 2 30k could occur that's
currently the price point that the P
Cycle moving average is representing
right now any sort of dip into the
moving average could take place if one
does occur this year then that would be
the next level to watch out for with
scope for downside deviation and
downside volatility below this orange
moving average but as we go into the
Haring year that's going to become less
likely that sort of downside at
deviation and oscillation in general
we'll probably see retesting of this
level and if you look at this moving
average generally it's ascending in the
same way that this green moving average
is also ascending because price is
ascending so the moving averages are
going to be reacting to that and this
green moving average on the other hand
that's around
53k and if we look to the pass for
instance to history in 2019 preh having
year we rejected from here and
experienced a strong retrace that's
probably not going to occur since we're
going into the harving year so you can
see here for instance in the Haring year
rejection very small rejection but then
break to new alltime highs in the preh
Haring year for instance in
2015 we didn't actually revisit this
moving average but then in the har year
we did and a kind of rejection which was
deeper then this small rejection here in
2020 also a having year there was a
rejection here so generally speaking if
we're going to be focusing on this green
moving average then there's scope for a
potential rejection from that region in
the harving year and that would be a
rejection that could be 20% 30% whatever
the case may be but we'll probably get
only one rejection from there because
the next time we get there we'll
probably break Beyond it quite
comfortably and the thing to note about
the P Cycle moving averages and
generally their crossovers we're we're
going to be talking about now when could
we potentially predict the price cycle
crossover because these crossovers of
the moving averages when the orange
overlaps with the green one we tend to
see bull market Peaks and this is a very
very accurate indicator for preceding
those bull market Peaks you can see here
right over here that was quite accurate
in the sense of marking out the local
top in the mid cycle but we probably
won't be seeing any more mid Cycles
going forward so this is predominantly a
bull market top indicator and if we
focus on when this price cycle crossover
could occur well first of all we need to
knowe that we're still way ways away 30k
is where this moving average is
representing price and 503k is where
this moving average is representing
price and of course a crossover we have
to have these moving averages get much
more closer to to each other so they
have to narrow over time this will occur
as price goes towards the upside in the
bull market we'll see this narrowing
occur but we're still a ways away from a
bull market Peak and if we were to just
extrapolate these two moving averages
when could we see a potential bull
market Peak and if you just do this for
instance you'll see that these moving
averages could almost go on forever and
the point here that I'm trying to make
is
that these are Dynamic moving averages
these are Dynamic moving averages and so
they're adjusting to price with every
price move and as price continues
towards the upside in the bull market
we'll see both of these moving averages
lift up and this moving average since
it's a 111 day moving average is going
to it's taking into account less days in
the moving average compared to this
moving average which is like 350 days
times two so this moving average is less
sensitive to price than this one and as
a result if price continues towards the
upside this is going to be the faster
moving average that's going to be
adjusting More Than This slower less
sensitive moving average and so this is
going to be chasing the green moving
average throughout the next two years so
as a result right now at this point in
time if we were to extrapolate the
moving averages then we can't come up
with a bull market Peak date because
they're just going in parallel for ages
and ages but once we see more inflection
on this moving average as price goes up
we're going to have an intersection at
some point of these moving averages in
the future so as time goes on and as
price increases we'll be able to conduct
this analysis and actually come up with
a relative estimation of when we'll be
able to see a potential bull market Peak
for Bitcoin in this cycle but then again
we always have to take into account that
these moving averages will be adjusting
to price but with time we'll be seeing a
narrowing as you can see for instance
here narrowing because in the preh
Haring year you can see that these two
moving averages are miles apart from
each other just like they are right now
in this cycle and just like they were in
the preh Haring year in 2015 as well but
then you see that these moving averages
well there's more compression here and
there's they just narrow and get closer
to each other and then finally they
cross over in a climax event where that
bull market Peak occurs within five 3 to
5 days if I'm not mistaken that's how
accurate this bull market top indicator
really is but the last thing that I'd
mention here is that this is a bull
market top indicator but it's also as
we've spoken about in this video it's
also a trend indicator where in a preh
Haring year we see oscillation around
this moving average but in the Haring
year we then retest this level as a
support and it's been the case across
history so this can be a trend indicator
in the same way that it's predominantly
a topping out indicator but this
indicator can offer a lot of insight
into how to understand price going
forward with this green moving average
potentially acting as a point of
rejection in the Haring year on the
first time of asking this moving average
potentially being that retesting
opportunity in the harving year that's
going to be the level that we're going
to be hammering out for support and so
that's going to be the reaccumulation
era in the harving year as we continue
in the uptrend and if we do buy some
sort
of some sort of event some Catalyst
forms and and causes a downside
deviation below this moving average then
that's even a better Roi outsid Roi
opportunity for investors for the long
run so the indicator here can give a lot
of insight especially the crossover the
crossover is nowhere near to happening
but will happen in the future but
probably still 2 years away subscribe to
the channel for more videos like this in
the future like this video if you enjoy
data science videos like this going
forward and check out the top right hand
corner video for more thanks so much for
watching and I'll speak to you in the
next one